[Music]
now jimmy uh you seem like a nice fellow
and i've known you
we sent you to this event you're very
nice to go
and uh my understanding was that you
were gonna go and just uh interview
people but you had a good idea i think
which was you decided you didn't want to
just cover the event you wanted to
participate as well is that right i want
to get my hands dirty a little bit so
what i did is i uh i set up my own
autographed table yeah and it pretended
i played a very minor character on the
tv show baywatch uh by the name of metal
detector mike so you
and you clearly did not you invented
this character that's right and you came
up with a whole backstory for metal
detector mike yes i did and uh you even
came up with headshots fake headshots i
commit to a roll yeah uh can we see this
is one of the head shots from metal
detector mike
what uh
yeah
what a horrible looking car
all right he was the comic relief this
guy's got a lot to say okay so you went
uh you disguised yourself with this
character and uh you tried to blend in
let's see what happened at the
collector's convention with jimmy pardo
[Music]
all right here we are the show just
opened up we had a prime location right
by the door martin landau is right
across the aisle tracy lord's not too
far away we've already had a few people
wonder who the hell i am i think it's
gonna be a good day
hour one starts now
morning
[Music]
i'm not even this guy and it upsets me
when nobody wants to stop and meet me
[Music]
what do you got in your pocket
whatever you got in your pocket i'll
take it
fair enough
how are you jim carter from baywatch jim
yeah
i was a metal detector mike for a couple
seasons yes sir did you watch the
program
oh yeah everybody watched me yeah right
you ever watched conan you ever watched
the tv show corner that guy makes me
laugh cohen is good yeah he's a little
off the deep end yeah but that's another
humor today how you doing okay good i
got a lot of the baywatch suits how many
suits do you have 65 and you have them
hanging on a wall or you just have them
in a box i got them in all different
places like frame them all up around
mannequins everything and like in a
basement or where the mannequins are
they're in my house jim here is on um
baywatch oh yeah good gloria all right
did you ever see him i know everybody
here kind of looks for bigger yeah
did you ever see him on big watch yes it
was about 115 degrees that day we were
all sweating our asses off i i'm not
kidding you i got in a fist fight almost
with wardrobe i said i'm not going out
there unless you give me some tight
speedos that's a true story everything
hanging out everything hanging out you
kidding me and hasselhoff was the one
that pulled the plug did you look so
good i think because i upstaged him i
think you're exactly right yeah i think
he was a little uncomfortable
here comes daddy with his package out
you know what i mean we used to call him
the hassle
around this set so i would go there he
is there's the hassle and that was me i
was a perfect strangers there for uh
an episode yeah i was also in the weird
science
back there as a kid you know you remind
me of right now who frank sinatra really
i was spent 35 years with him and dean
martin and sammy davis and i remind you
of frank sinatra your personality honey
he was so funny
you don't realize i'm more than
flattered and i'm probably going to have
somebody whacked
remember of course i do well
well you're there too well i should tell
you one thing we don't have in common
well he was known for something
yes
i don't have that at all do they know
what we're talking about yes everybody
knows what we're talking about milton
berle had a huge crank he was so funny
yeah
and he would get up there and talk about
his schlong
well it was supposed to be humongous
it was
[Music]
boom yeah
we're lowering it we're going to six
that ought to bring him in
hey oh
i would that was that was my catchphrase
well isn't that special
that was my catchphrase
[Music]
me
[Applause]
you're an idiot